[Music]
[Music]
good morning just letting the pews fill
up a little bit as the church is open
turn your hymnal page 69
Knute
[Music]
mmm we're gonna get into today's Sunday
morning sermon
[Music]
mm-hmm Megan uh bowl Church spiritual by
humming like it sounded like when I was
a kid in church okay I was I got up this
morning and I was tweeting and this
thing happened nothing bad but it I said
oh this is her story this is a lesson so
there's a I'm just looking at the tweets
here there's a Twitter site called
attractions
I guess attractions magazine and they
cover theme park stuff I guess you know
particularly Disney maybe and they wrote
a tweet the other day April 4 it is is a
kingdom keeper series in development for
Disney Plus according to Kevin Smith it
is I am that Kevin Smith for those that
are unfamiliar with the kingdom keeper
series of books they were written by
Ridley Pearson as fascinating story
Ridley wrote a book about you know what
happens at Disneyland for Disney World
or land one of them I think it was World
when the park closes and like the park
comes to life after after dark Park
after dark Disney after dark so he did a
whole series of books and he didn't even
do it with Disney wasn't like he got
permission from Disney just wrote it
himself they became so popular Disney
was like alright and they sell those
books in the Disney park man so like
when people tell you like don't use
other people's IP and stuff like that
like you never know Ridley Pearson
[ __ ] turned it into a series of books
so Jon Favreau
years ago was gonna make a movie I
believe of Kingdom Keepers and then it
wanted away and then he did I think
Jungle Book and spin and now he's doing
Mandalorian which [ __ ] I love the
Mandalorian so there was a moment in
time when the Disney Channel did the
Disney that well Disney Plus
so I was called yes Disney Plus the app
didn't have a name it was in development
but they didn't have a name for it yet
and in the beginning of the life of
Disney plus the Disney Channel was put
in charge of the creative so the folks
that you know brought you high school
musical and whatnot they were in charge
of the the channel and some agent one
day called me and said hey the folks at
Disney wanted to meet with you and this
is a couple years ago I put up a tweet
where I was like I'm working with the
biggest I ever worked with this was it
um it was right before the heart attacks
it's all happening and then I was
working on it after the heart attack as
well
so my agent was like hey Disney wants to
talk to you about their hearing pitches
on this show Kingdom Keepers they want
to do for their this new app they're
gonna the Netflix like app that they're
making and stuff which we now all know
is Disney Plus so uh I said Disney wants
to talk to me like I haven't dealt with
Disney since Disney owned Miramax back
in the day when we were when I was a kid
Disney owned all my early movies and
then they sold Miramax bought Marvel
instead much smarter business decision
so is it going and and if you want and I
said you know what that like I'll go in
for the [ __ ] just to watch their
expressions change so I said I'm pitched
in a long time especially a lot of gone
a corporate level
[ __ ] y'all goin man so I came up with a
storyline I wrote this you know outline
for what it was and stuff basically
wrote the pitch down and you know when
you pitch in a room you're talking to
people and looking at their faces so
when I went to Disney Channel to meet
the folks and pitch Gary was guys in
charge there and stuff I said hey man
like like I'm too old to [ __ ] play
this pitch game and stuff so like do you
mind if I read this [ __ ] right off my
laptop I brought my laptop with me and
like I'll you know it's the pitch I'm
just gonna it's easier to read in this
way I won't forget anything and it's way
more involved on the page and all if it
helps I'll just look up
you guys from time to time you know make
sure we're making eye contact if you and
they were like get go ahead so I pitched
I read my pitch document and you know
what they told me that like here's what
we want from the book the rest just kind
of you know let's hear what you would
like to do so if you're a kingdom
keepers book fan the you know it
deviated from the book so if you're like
man I wanted to see that you might not
want to see it because like it was my
version that matched up with Ridley's
idea so I pitched that and in it
Ridley's books they're wonderful reads
but they're you know they pick one of
the villains and kind of stick with that
villain and stuff yeah when when I was
told this is what they're looking for it
they were like just you know go Disney
nuts man and so I took that to be like
well [ __ ] this is the Avengers of Disney
so I can use every IP that the parks got
yeah there's some obvious like you know
you would want to touch tour Wars and
show like that but in the classic park
it was gonna be set in Disneyland and
stuff so all that stuff was fair game
and you could literally like you know
like Walt was a character Mickey Mouse
of course was character but you know he
didn't pop up until [ __ ] later but he
was always around every character the
main villain was Captain Hook
so who I wanted Russell Brand for so you
know I went in pitched that they were
like I did it just because I'm like well
you know I work I'm not really in
Hollywood I live in Hollywood I don't
really work in the business but
sometimes I do I'm outside business on
business adjacent I kind of we do our
own thing over here but you know there
have been times where I've been in that
world and it been a while so I was like
let me like see this for the [ __ ] I
got nothing to do and they went from my
pitch it was crazy they were like you
know we like it let's do and they made a
deal and I started writing the show for
Disney Plus well it wasn't called Disney
Plus then it was called like the the
Disney
a Netflix like app a very long title I
think they were calling it DTC
direct-to-consumer app so I went to work
with the kids at the Disney Channel
they were my my execs and I had a
[ __ ] blast it was one of the most
enjoyable times I ever had creating
something I would find even more joy
later on doing masters in the universe
but man these kids like when I was first
in this business the studio execs and
stuff they weren't creative they were
suits you know these kids were all
writers former writers that they were
like let's at certain point they were
like let's make writers the execs in
charge of this [ __ ] so all they all had
great [ __ ] ideas and showed me how to
shape like a series and set up should
pay it off and whatnot [ __ ] that's
obvious if you watch TV but like when
you're doing it yourself like well I
didn't think about and then they were
like you could do this and I'm like oh
[ __ ] that's what they do on TV so it was
an education to man the whole time this
was going on I swear to you from the
moment I went in to pitch all throughout
the writing process I said this is never
going to happen there's no way this ever
happens but [ __ ] it I'll go with the
first long as it is well all has got to
be worth a story insurer Plus don't get
me wrong they paid me to do the you know
writing and stuff so but the whole time
I was like this ain't never gonna
[ __ ] move forward stuff so but we
kept moving forward man and I got wrote
the pilot script and there was a full
Bible for the entire arc of the first
you know season and stuff which would
have basically told the story of the
first book and you know that shockingly
the good folks at Disney Channel we're
into it now I couldn't believe it and
stuff and I was like oh my god man maybe
like maybe this might that man and I
would say it's never gonna happen
then like it started getting real like
you know that if you see all the behind
the scenes footage on the mandalorian
they got those video walls that create a
backdrop and [ __ ] they brought me over
Disney to show me that like years ago
like this is going to be the future and
there's a big wall and they put
this post-industrial backdrop and like I
sat there with my phone and as I moved
it moved and [ __ ] it was [ __ ] dope
and like this is what we'd like to use
as the backgrounds you know rather than
green-screen [ __ ] and like your money oh
god yeah this looks expensive as [ __ ]
yeah let's I guess you want this let's
do this I met with a producer up in
Vancouver well I was working on an
episode of Supergirl and went through
like budgets and potential places to
shoot like it just kept inching more
toward reality and I was like holy [ __ ]
man this actually might happen still
hadn't named the Disney Plus app yet but
they were like this is gonna be one of
our first shows we've already greenlit
High School Musical the series and we're
this is like next so that'll start it
and then this is gonna happen Kingdom
Keepers they're like we love it we love
the it's all the Disney IP at once and I
did I used everything everything that
you could see in the park they all
[ __ ] came to life and [ __ ] so I was
over in England visiting Jay Jay when he
was shooting rise of Skywalker was that
the period yes
staying in Slough from from the office
the British the office and I got the you
know email from my agent going like
Kingdom Keepers been killed and I was
what what happened man like like oh my
god are you kidding and this was the the
word there's a new exec that was brought
in on the app at the on what would
become Disney Plus and he read it and
this is what here let me get back to my
tweet so they put up this tweet
attractions magazine is Kingdom keeper
series in development for Disney plus
according to Kevin Smith it is I must
have talked about it on a podcast or
something but they misunderstood thought
it was currently in active development
so I wrote on Twitter that was a blast
to write two years ago it was planned as
one of the first shows to launch on what
would become Disney Plus then a new exec
was put in charge of the app and he
killed KK Kingdom keepers said we use to
my
Disney IP and one project every parent
character can the park come select that
was true that was the reason I was given
the thing was killed I was like oh my
god did the new guy did not like the
script miz' there wasn't that said
there's too much [ __ ] IP in the show
you use every day I'm Disney character
in one they didn't think this was a good
idea so thing got killed so I was never
like really overly upset because I never
thought it would happen anyone should
it's their channel and their [ __ ]
property so I'm certainly not gonna be
like no and it wasn't even my book it
was really Pearson's book so you know I
got paid very well and stuff and I got
to work with really cool people and [ __ ]
and they were so sweet and like I got to
go to Disney after dark I walked up on
the on on Space Mountain when it's
closed we walked the [ __ ] track man I
was like oh my god this is what are
there's an episode set on Space Mountain
which was inverted it was really a
canyon or something but uh like they
were eating I was like this is what the
town should look like it was a mining
town [ __ ] we should just used the look
at his place got you know shot my phone
video went into Walt's apartment with
the candle light that's always on and
stuff like that so I got to do very cool
things and then suddenly went away and I
was like you know I didn't I honestly I
was like we were so close to like all
right maybe we'll push Jay and Silent
Bob reboot for a year and just focus on
this and I and I was like you know maybe
we'll just keep them both spin in just
in case and my experience can't ever bet
on anything and so thankfully when they
were like this ain't happened and I was
like well we're gonna go make Jay and
Silent Bob reboot no harm no foul so I
won't put up this tweet this morning
just to be like hey man that show is old
news and not happening in blah blah blah
but you know the keyline about the then
a new exec was put in charge of the app
and he killed Ken
a lot of people of course were like who
this [ __ ] exec so somebody wrote who
was Steven Santonio it was a nice dude
it's not like he did wrong but Steven
writes that new exact sounds like he has
no idea what people would and wouldn't
watch and it does based on my tweet
sound like that so I had to follow up
with this tweet and this is the
important part of the lesson I said the
Disney Plus exact may have scrapped
Kingdom Keepers but he's all
so the guy who said let's do Star Wars
and Marvel Studios shows so as much as I
would have liked to make my show I'm
much happier watching the Mandalorian
and can't wait for wand division and
then I hashtag that fan first filmmaker
second because that's kind of true the
important lesson here of course is like
in the moment you know I was like oh man
like that show didn't happen and we all
worked on it and I had something to
distract me and stuff but like oh man
you know what what was the point of all
that and stuff like that or oh man why'd
they scrapped partial or oh man this new
guy scrapped our show that new guy came
in and said let's do all this and those
are all the shows I actually want to
watch [ __ ] loved Amanda Laurie man I
watched that show it makes me feel like
I'm nine years old and [ __ ] takes me
right back to the 70s so I would much up
fan first filmmaker second long before I
was making [ __ ] for a living I was just
got watched [ __ ] and still am a person
that just like likes watching [ __ ] so I
was never like you know oh man [ __ ] this
guy and [ __ ] Disney and [ __ ] like that
but I didn't want people of course like
you know to feel the same way like this
guy ruined everything this guy [ __ ]
gave us the shows you want to watch I
can't I literally cannot wait to watch
[ __ ] Quan Division the Falcon and
Winter Soldier and [ __ ] like that give
me every goddamn Marvel show so the
lesson is you know sometimes in a moment
you're like ah [ __ ] you know that would
that sucks and then you know you wait 10
minutes and [ __ ] don't suck anymore
something positive comes out of
something potentially perceived as
negative there's a wonderful moment in
the movie what was it called Charlie
Wilson's War Tom Hanks Philip Seymour
Hoffman was written by Aaron Sorkin and
he tells the story about you know the
the little boy in the village gets a
a horse and everybody's like oh how
wonderful and then the village wise
man's like we'll see and then the little
boy falls off the horse
and breaks his leg and everyone's like
oh my god how horrible and the village
Wiseman says we'll see and then a war
breaks out so they're taking all the
young men to war but this guy can't go
because his legs broken and everyone's
like how lucky and then the old man's
like we'll see and so forth and so on so
you know you can't ever judge in a
moment life is full of those moments and
they all add up to something at the end
and stuff but the game is constantly
changing in the middle of play man he
can't nothing that happens is permanent
good or bad
you know we're Americans so we like to
believe that like what a good thing
happens it's got Bailey's way forever
and [ __ ] and as we've just seen recently
by that were like current events you
know you can't always count on that
thing good thing staying a good thing
forever and stuff but you can't always
be like oh the good thing stopped and
now it's all bad because then good
things come from bad things man you know
what George Carlin say life is a
zero-sum game like at the end of the day
you know people try to amass wealth
they're not blasting people for wanting
money I'm a capitalist as much as the
next person maybe not as much as some
people maybe not good at it I guess is
the point but you know when you try to
amass like a bunch of wealth eventually
like life ends and you know the Oh like
god I missed a lot of cool [ __ ] I mean
you know it's not maybe you didn't miss
maybe you make choices and sometimes you
feel like that's what I want more than
anything and then sometimes that choice
winds up being your undoing and stuff
and sometimes a [ __ ] you back into winds
up defining you George Carlin didn't
want to be a comedian stand-up comedian
you wanted to be Danny Kaye I wanted to
be a song-and-dance man in movies and
stuff comedy was just something he
backed into he's like I could do this
for now and it defined his entire life
is one of the greatest comedians that
ever lived so you never know kid
that's the point of that Disney Plus
story eventually the channel was called
Disney Plus and here here's a sweet
little PS to that story so there was an
exec in that room when I pitched Kingdom
keepers who left Disney shortly
thereafter he went and joined a company
called Mattel and one day I got a phone
call from my agent gone the folks at
Mattel want to talk to you about
something I said really what all right
you know what I'll go where is nice and
Santa Monica is a [ __ ] Santa Monica I
ain't going like that's too far cause
it's like a half an hour away and
traffic e and they were like well you
know you might but what if they came to
your house I said okay if they're coming
my house I'm [ __ ] totally take the
meeting and the guy there were two guys
one was Rob David who I worked with
almost every day the other guy was a guy
who worked at Disney he was in the room
when I did my pitch and so he had said
to Rob like hey what about Kevin Smith
for this master universe thing he gave a
pinch of Disney right before I left for
Kingdom Keepers I really like and so
they reached out to me and came over and
I was like oh my god I would love to do
that so there you go man Disney Channel
thing with a Disney plus thing didn't
happen but it led to and nobody was ever
gonna see it but it led to masters the
universe you never [ __ ] know that's
why you don't [ __ ] to Lafley in life
I've learned that man [ __ ] like you
know I wish I hadn't bitched when I got
thrown off the [ __ ] airplane or not
so much I wish I'm [ __ ] I was so
mortified by that mama cuz I was like
the whole world figured out I'm [ __ ]
fat at once that I didn't have fun with
it and I'm person that tries that fun
with everything and usually a sense of
humor about everything that moment
changed me in as much as it did teach me
like hey you're as much as you think
you're [ __ ] like funny for a living
apparently you're very touchy about this
[ __ ] subject and [ __ ] like that and
so you know I remember David Letterman
like the Letterman Show when he was
still you know The Late Night with David
Letterman they were like oh my god come
to the top ten and I was like no I can't
like what
I'm [ __ ] humiliated by this like oh my
god like what and then Jon Stewart on
The Daily Show it was like come on the
show we'll get an airplane seat and show
that you could fit in it and I was like
what no my god don't you get it this
mortifying and now in retrospect I'm
like why the [ __ ] didn't I do both of
those things man just own this [ __ ]
[ __ ] like it's crazy so you know and in
a moment you never know man bad thing
could become a good thing a great thing
to become a horrible thing
you just gotta ride ride the slide kids
there it is
as Rev Cavs Sunday morning sermon I am a
reverend by the way the [ __ ] ordained
in the Universal Life Church man or oak
as we call it thanks for hanging out
here in that story so remember men if
you don't get a kingdom keepers you
could get a Mandalorian and that's
[ __ ] way better for my money
alright thanks for making me feel
relevant on a Sunday morning somewhere
back in time is 8:30 right here I'm an
altar boy back in the day so 19 let me
see I would come an altar boy 1970 had
to be in second grade so 1977-78 and I
was an altar boy up to when I graduated
all pH our lady perpetual help
and so you know that was 1983 June of 83
and I even served Mass a little bit
after that even though I went to a
public high school so my point being
somewhere in the streams of time is 8:30
on a Sunday out here in Los Angeles
right now but somewhere in the streams
of time it's 8:30 on a Sunday morning in
Highlands new jersey circa 1981 82 and
I'm serving a mass you know watching the
priests and go maybe I want to be priest
one day and then I realized I don't
wanna be a priest I just wanted to be on
stage in front of people I just wanted
people to have to listen to me that's
why I like that job of quick stop
because like you know people need
cigarettes they got to talk to you any
event thank you for letting me feel like
it was a Sunday morning again and this
time I'm in damn pulpit rev keV all
right
on 4/20 Universal is doing a focus films
focus features is doing a live watch a
long screening of Mallrats movie that I
made 25 [ __ ] years ago that I'll be
hosting or whatever so find out where
that information is and tonight I'm a me
and Ralph might try to livestream
Hollywood babble-on so hopefully soon
you